nos piden que expresemos el punto sobre
la recta numérica como fracción iv en
decimal pausa en el vídeo para que lo
intente bueno hagámoslo juntos aquí
podemos ver que el punto en cuestión se
encuentra en un valor que es mayor a 4
pero menor a 5 mayor a 4 y menor a 5 y
el espacio que hay entre 4 y 5 está
dividido en 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
secciones iguales entonces si cada una
de estas marcas representa una décima
parte aquí tenemos 4 esto corresponde a
4 con una décima y este es cuatro con
dos décimas y si queremos escribirlo en
forma de fracción o de número mixto
tenemos cuatro enteros y dos décimos
pero si queremos escribirlo en decimales
sería cuatro y después tenemos dos
décimas
hemos terminado hagamos otro ejemplo
nuevamente nos piden que expresemos el
punto que hay sobre la recta numérica
como fracción iv decimal pero esto es un
poco diferente analicemos primero en que
es diferente y después contestemos la
pregunta pausa en el vídeo y traten de
resolver bueno como podemos ver aquí el
punto no se encuentra entre dos números
enteros sino que más bien se encuentra
entre dos décimas porque estamos entre
3.2 es decir tres enteros y dos décimas
y 3.3 o tres enteros y tres décimas así
que cada una de estas marcas representan
un décimo de décimas o dicho de otra
manera es una centésima parte una forma
de verlo es que 3.2 son tres enteros y
veinte centésimas mientras que 3.3 son
tres enteros y treinta centésimas
entonces aquí tenemos tres enteros y
veinte centésimas
3 enteros y 21 centésimas y finalmente
tenemos 3 enteros y 22 centésimas este
punto corresponde a 3 enteros
y 22 centésimas es decir 3.22 y claro
vamos a describirlo como un número mixto
aquí tenemos 3 enteros y 22 entre 100
otra forma en la que podríamos haberlo
resuelto es que si empezamos en 3.2 o
tres enteros
y dos décimas a eso le añadimos no
solamente una centésima sino dos así que
nos quedan tres enteros dos décimas y
después dos centésimas ahí lo tiene lo
hemos expresado como fracción y como
decimal